so valve just announced the biggest
match fixing bans in the history of dota
former ti winner faith and his
ti-winning org newbie
were both permanently banned after being
found guilty of match fixing
but the thing that makes us unique is
actually how long valve
took to put these bands into place after
the initial allegations
it's a big disaster but it could also be
a big moment for dota
[Music]
hey guys we at the score esports are on
the march to 2 million subscribers
we'd love to see the support for the
channel so far but we're hoping to make
that 2 million number come true soon
so if you haven't already please hit
that subscribe button ring the
notification bell
and let us know what you want to see
from our content in the future in the
comments below
so this news is huge a roster with a
former ti winner and an
org that's known primarily for dota have
just been
permanently banned from valve events but
the news wasn't entirely a surprise
because
back in may it was revealed that chinese
esports organization
newbie and their dota 2 roster had been
permanently banned from in the tv events
because of match fixing allegations the
allegations surfaced after newbie played
a match against a different team
of vengerals in an upper bracket match
at ladder imba tv miner season 3.
and side note what the hell kind of name
is avengers that's
really weird there was some pretty
suspicious play including newbie
completely dropping game one
and then making miraculous comebacks in
game two and three
you know the sort of thing that would
make for some pretty awesome gambling
odds if you knew
exactly what was gonna happen next
radiance
i present to you the wind probability
graph with no comment
imagine whatever you want the series was
clearly suspicious even at the time and
newbie was banned from in the tv
mars media and cda events back in may
2020. the info was supposedly given to
valve at that point
but it's taken nearly 8 months for them
to do anything about it
all of newbies roster and the
organization itself
were banned from valve events on january
3rd
then the next day the avengers roster
that they had played against
was also permanently banned from valve
events so
why the hell did valve wait 8 months to
do anything
how does that make sense even in the
context of
valve time like yeah maybe you want to
argue
that valve was doing their own
investigation and that takes time
that's fine they should absolutely be
diligent about making sure their
investigation is complete
but eight months when even the caster
was questioning these games as
suspicious
at the time they were played valve has
notoriously taken
a very hands-off approach to their
esports titles
but dota has been here before in fact
dota was the reason that valve had to
say
hey if you match fix we're going to
[ __ ] can you
that's because in 2013 dota 2 player
alexei solo berezin
was caught throwing a game and betting
on it for the amount of 322 dollars
leading to the famous 3-2-2 meme
but also a short-term ban and listen i
love the meme
i made an entire video about the meme
back when they let me just
make videos about memes you might
remember it
those were great times what are you
doing with your hands
anyways after that solo match fixing
incident
valve apparently told all the teams at
ti4
that if your players match fix it's just
gonna be a lifetime ban
from here on out solo got a slap on the
wrist and
was of course immortalized as a meme for
match fixing
but from that point onward if any player
match fixed
the penalty was an immediate lifetime
ban from valve events
and we saw those rules enforced with of
course the eye by power situation in cs
go
arguably the most famous time that that
happened
but the esports integrity commission
recently issued bans to seven
australian cs go players who were
playing in the mountain dew league and
that happened in october 2020
that investigation is also still ongoing
okay so
back to dota if you don't follow dota
the organization that won
ti4 was newbie
yeah so they knew about the rules about
as early as anyone could
and it's not like these rules were
really a secret now a ban from valve
events is
basically a death sentence for your
career in dota
because the international a valve event
is what the
fans of the game really spend their time
dreaming about the action defies
logic and the prize pools are massive
without ti dota 2 would be a lot
different and if you
can't play a ti well good luck finding a
team that wants to skip out on millions
in prize money
to play with you a hypothetical match
fixer
the newbie roster that valve just banned
hadn't really been playing together
since may but now their careers are
basically over
that includes faith who not only won the
international two
but he came top eight at ti4 and placed
second at ti7 if a roster playing for
one of the region's most storied orgs
and that includes a ti winner was match
fixing
it kind of makes you wonder how many
more of these orgs are doing the exact
same thing
and just making it way less obvious than
these guys did
seriously the [ __ ] was blatant they see
the invoker
the smoke is coming jessica what are you
doing
farming
not enough respect maybe thought that
newbie were just gonna go rush or
something like that but
and listen for obvious reasons 2020
wasn't kind to dota we're talking about
a game
that's truly international with multiple
strong regions that could win it all
but whether you typically prefer the
laissez-faire valve approach
or riot's tight control of their scene
you can't deny that riot was the company
that gave us the best esports
championship of 2020
while valve just canceled the
international i don't have a lot of
sympathy for match fixers and we know
that they
got the punishment that was expected by
basically everyone
but why the hell did this take so long
and while the delay seems to have had a
minimal impact on the competition that's
happened since may
it might not always be that way and does
valve even care about that
what if months and months of competitive
results had been retroactively affected
by this
trying to figure out how or why valve
does anything
is kind of like trying to figure out why
your dad never came back from his trip
to the gas station to get cigarettes 15
years ago
you won't be satisfied with the answer
and it'll probably destroy your faith in
humanity
i think it's good that this was handled
before the start of the dota pro circuit
which is set to start a couple weeks
from now
but isn't that the lowest possible bar
for valve to clear
and shouldn't dota fans for whom 2020
was admittedly a disappointment
expect more from valve if they want to
see
dota back where it rightfully belongs
sometimes i like like say [ __ ] and i'm
like wow i [ __ ] sound like devon
it's a weird experience because i'm used
to it being like oh i sound like my dad
right now for for clarity in case
anyone's wondering devin is not my dad
even though he has like the actual dad
beard and i'm like clean shaven all the
time
devin's not my dad devin's more like
he'd be like my lumberjack friend
i think like i'd be like yo my
lumberjack friend devin made some
moonshine so we're gonna go
we're gonna go chill in his weird cabin
like honestly
we should you know what we should do
dude we should make moonshine and call
it like
whoa whoa but i [ __ ] love it we're
literally telling them how to react to
it
you know like it's it's like next level
marketing it's like but if we had like a
soft drink
i'm just gonna say soft drink so that
nobody can attack me
and it was called like [ __ ] yes you know
what i'm saying so
like like maybe you even open the can
and it kind of like sounds like it says
that
you know what i'm saying we're just it's
just a drink experience but it's all
subliminal
well actually it's not really subliminal
to call your to call your drink [ __ ] yes
no that's pretty explicit i would drink
some [ __ ] yes though